what do the gaming retail education in
agricultural industries have in common
many of them are optimizing their
workflows and increasing their
efficiency using Google compute engine
Google compute engine lets you create
and run virtual machines on Google
infrastructure compute engine offers
scale performance and value that allows
you to easily launch large compute
clusters on Google's infrastructure you
can run your Windows applications on
Google compute engine and take advantage
of many benefits available to virtual
machine instances such as reliable
storage options the speed of the Google
Network and auto scaling in this
QuickStart lab you will learn how to
launch a Windows Server instance in
Google compute engine and connect it to
using the remote desktop protocol you do
not need a Google cloud platform account
or project an account project and
associated resources are provided to you
as part of this lab on creek labs this
is the second lab in the GCP essentials
quest a quest is a series of related
labs that form a learning path
completing this quest earns you this
badge to recognize your achievement you
can make your batch for badges public
and link to them in your online resume
or social media account next up on your
quest is getting started with Google
shell and G cloud